what's up what's up thank you thank you
thank you for coming out before we get
started I just want to say that you know
we've done this now for three years and
it means so much to us at first we feast
that you guys line up and then fill the
place up and come in with so much
enthusiasm so yeah make some noise for
yourselves make some noise for
yourselves and I know what you're
thinking I see the bald guy I see the
wings I see the sauces where's the
guests well anyone who's been with us
since day one knows that some of our
favorite interviews are with rap legends
from Nouri to Redman to Trick Daddy and
here at complex con it made just as much
sense to keep that proud tradition going
so our next guest he's been in the game
for more than 30 years released two
dozen studio albums over that time he's
the professor of slang guaa snakes and
of course earl stevens fine wine
everybody makes some noise for e-40
[Applause]
it's over but on this side I'll be on
this side Shannon would it not a [ __ ]
y'all doing
are you ready to get started
correct all right so this first one is
the classic again we'll start at the
handle it's cool I'll dress that mm-hmm
so anyone who knows efore D knows that
you rep yeah area to the fullest
especially when it comes to your Golden
State Warriors in San Francisco 49ers so
on winged one we have some questions for
front row forty David draymond Green
story you can share with us yeah I got
one last night he was how he beat my ass
view my ass on we played the best sadhus
we the best out of seven two series and
he got me on ball from the first me why
me I was for the one like man damn I'm
rusty man I got to get back into this
you and I play dominoes and hella moons
and whatnot so cuz I've been you know I
had time to eat a fortune cookie you
feel me so I've been Hillary Busey is
there a celebrity fan you have the most
fun sitting courtside with one dude I
was my god he said right behind me or
fool would I follow him on Instagram I
was handbook zine what's his handle Z
why you so much fun yeah he'd be fine I
could be talking a hell of [ __ ] - all
the [ __ ] the rival teams and
[ __ ] [ __ ] you you know you want to come
down from the stands you feel me
but something that might surprise people
about your friend Marshawn Lynch he like
Hennessy he a cognac here and also - you
walked the parade route in these victory
parades all the time ever seen anything
crazy from the parade route hold on let
me take you some goodies yeah yeah
that's the way to do it the parade
routes is just you know the energy just
the fans out there you know they fired
up you know with a winning squad you
know it's not a lot of violence and then
you know we're not gonna would but
everybody's having everybody in great
spirits alright so this next one is the
humble house
you know it's good you like that one so
forward to four to forty huh mm-hmm
so you're the undisputed king of slang
you've even popularized and coined
full-blown household catch phrases like
fo sheezy and pop your collar is there a
phrase that holds a special place in
your heart either the way it rolls off
the tongue or what it means to you one
of my favors slapping because everybody
say that's slap right there you feel me
just slap a slapping you know man you
like did you get that song I sent you
bro yes slap right you like that yeah
which is a higher-ranking title
lieutenant roast a botch or Captain
save-a-ho that's a good question right
there if you like that well you know
which one wins I'm not gonna tell you
the one the one that it should be as
lieutenant roaster botch far ass you
know the rules and regulations of the
gang okay but due to the fact that the
rules and regulations of the game has
been changed captain save-a-ho is very
notorious in this world you feel me it
isn't working same holds in lieutenant
roster boxes you feel me all right so
let's do a little slang free association
what I want to do is hit you with some
words that are trending in hip hop right
now and you just tell me what you think
the first thing that comes to mind okay
drip drip jury savage beastie clout uh
yes damn be a fixture skirt a ski skirt
Artie Ford are you ready to move on he
all right so this next one the butterfly
bakery Honda number three
I can never go wrong what I use so you
couldn't so you couldn't have you in the
seat without talking about the patron
saint of first we feast I'm talking
about your friend Guy Fieri mm-hmm we
see a sitting courtside with the donkey
sauce God all the time what can you tell
us about your relationship with him
you know me seeing him I'm a fan first
of all watching this you know watching
him on TV and then I got a chance to you
know over the years seem a course I'd
and would not and and I mean we became
real close they're people and in the
same way that you've pioneered a lot of
the enduring hip-hop slang he's done the
same with Kitchen lingo yeah so what I
want to do is hit you with some of the
most iconic Fieri isms of all time and
as a tenured professor in slang twist
excuse what you think okay put it on a
flip flop put it on the flip flop that's
food that's so good you can eat it off
of a flip-flop oh wait my game up wait
my game do you like that I like that
it's [ __ ] around
how about bomb.com bomb.com that's
normal speak
that's the bomb.com everybody know that
one bomb.com has he ever used flavortown
in everyday conversation are you say
flavortown I don't say flavortown a few
times really yeah
uh and then what about hot frisbee of
fun have you ever heard of hot frisbee
never heard that when I was beat that
was deep so yeah that is anything that
is round and delicious like pancakes or
a burger oh you go in this is Catarina
Heba cutie that's why they called the
guy and has one more for you it's my
favorite that puts the Shamma Lamma and
ding dong I heard that one guy all like
that one breath I'm gonna talk to you
about that one all right are you ready
to move on down the line up this one
right here mm-hmm
I like mango Oh what's wrong
just retry my mango Moscato is available
at Total Wine
[Applause]
that's [ __ ] hot too a little bit here
starting to get to a show for show I
need just milk them and no milk ain't
good for black people get up here get
the bubble guns get the bus to pattern
the popped it off so you're a rare
example of an MC that's been around to
have songs with Tupac and then also be
on Vince staples latest yeah yeah I'm
curious what you think about these hip
hop flare-ups that have been happening
when like a young MC is interviewed and
maybe they can't name a single biggie or
POC song because on one hand you seem to
be very open to the changing times but I
know that there's a little sprinkle of
grumpy veteran in ya know what makes you
think that brother I just what I see not
you know islands you know as I get older
I get wiser you know and I understand a
lot of these cast was you know they just
did there wasn't even born a teens a lot
of more teens and you know in the early
20s you feel me so you're living your
learn but I'm not knocking none of them
they get any money I was telling us just
saving and just you know get some side
hustles and stay humble and keep it
pushing being here in Long Beach I think
it's important that we shout out Snoop
Dogg Hulu book never have done never not
family choice that's cut a Snoopy come
on Snoopy can't Snoopy then kicked it in
Vallejo with us you know who you would
robbers you know come kick it at your
house like and hang out for a few days
like you feel me Snoop NATO RP Nate Dogg
I remember Nate Dogg
come on legendary man shout-out to the
dog pound man yeah so you know nice
number love that's like our family
Snoopy and the dog pound although man
you know know me as someone whose career
spans Tupac - too short yg - Vince
staples I think you're uniquely
qualified to weigh in on this
what's your West Coast rap Mount
Rushmore top four MCS to do it from the
side was a tough one hmm
fix my my yes my Cartier's of course you
know I gotta put the Foley wad up and
that [ __ ] spit too much game man
he 42 short Ice Cube Snoop it is put it
in stone put it in stone key 40 ready
for the next wing yes sir so this is
Louis Caliente slows calientes
liking that one yeah I like that
that's lugging around thank you be 40
well it's a shout-out to Lowe's
calientes shout out Lowe's calientes
let's make some noise for Louis Kelly in
our d40 we have a recurring segment on
our show called explain that Graham
where you do a deep dive and our guests
Instagram interesting pictures that need
more context so for you guys out here
maybe the picture will show up here or
on these monitors on the wing for you
and me e-40 we can look here at one of
these to see the pictures we throw up
the first pic what is the first pick you
and Martha oh [ __ ] she is she she's
smooth man's like she be she be chilling
breath so they said the bottle rock the
bottle rockets at a festival in Napa
California now that they throw every
year's big big festival Martha had her
little tent Sasha
they say Martha Stewart in there go ha
later I went in there she had a little
bit me and my wife went there she had a
doctor reason wouldn't I see you just
hello just smooths chillin i hey come
have a seat see super koala
I love humble people you feel me she is
super cool you and yeh you and Kanye
powerhouse that's the world's that we
was there you know I'm say let's get a
pig but I met Kanye years ago
you feel me many moons ago he grew up on
my music as well you feel me and it was
beautiful because we during a time me
and Big Sean had a big record called I
don't [ __ ] with you maybe you've heard
of him you know I'm sad I'm [ __ ] with
you you little stupid-ass [ __ ]
it kind when they first hit me like I
got to record I did my part
shoddy it is they said Kanye want to do
do his parts to it so he put a little
sample to it at the beginning and I was
like this is my [ __ ] genius his music
you can't knock what he do for us music
me he's a super producer man you're not
amazed that thing together like the
weather you know he put it together like
the web alright one more one more let's
throw it up you in the rock do you
remember what rock the rock boy I grew
up on watching his daddy it was called
big-time wrestling it wasn't his daddy
man was Rocky Johnson you feel me
Rocky Johnson was the best wrestler in
the game him and moon dog man
just remember their name Google moon dog
man were you ok he was meny ok this is a
Caucasian dude hillbilly styled the
whole while he was with this [ __ ] ok but
I chopped it up with him and that was
that cameo on chewie gonna show early in
the morning and he was like yeah man I
grew up on you he 40 sugar - you be
legit sugar t D shy to click the hole
will whop you feel really got Berry at
title but not we just chopping it up man
dupa do super cool and I wish he would
run for president you feel what I'm
saying I think he had knew it man the
rock the rock 2020 you heard it here
first are you ready to move on Eve 40
what we gonna do now
now we're gonna go with the Clark and
Hopkins society Schiff gonna start
getting high
I'll play too much just knocking - he's
got kind of a curry all right say I'll
prepare myself for this few minutes ago
when I was eating up onions don't go
happy
so let me set myself up this is good
though but it's hot yes damn awful hot
yeah it's getting real over here it's
kicking in so wanna take it back to when
you were growing up on Magazine Street
coming up in Vallejo at an interesting
time politically you had the rise of the
Black Panthers in Oakland and I read an
interesting story back in 2011 you and
Snoop Dogg took Young Jeezy aside in
between scenes for a music video and
told them that it needs to use this
voice to be a leader not just a rapper
do you remember that moment what you
guys talked about I remember something
like that
if did Jeezy say that that if he said
that that's what we said cuz we own I
got never loved for cheesy well you
notice I'm [ __ ] we you know I chop real
gang when I'm amongst my my my rap
partners and just everybody I just try
to keep him one thought well when he's
been doing that too you know I like what
ti speaks house a lot of men a lot of
cats really speak out and just you know
speak their mind tell the truth and they
already famous or ain't really got to do
it but they just stand it for something
you gotta stand for something why are
you gonna fall for anything
well society 40 are you ready to move on
my man was wiggle so this next one is
the firewater along the first wicket is
wanna Rex smart that's smart
[Music]
whoa this one hot over the harbor still
but it's hot
mm-hmm just hanging around - it won't
leave take a little bite of that mm-hmm
but if I was a late-night Munchie
someone come from a clue [ __ ] them uh
those up so we just got the opportunity
to talk a little bit during a panel that
we just had we got to talk about efore
tea and the Earl Stephens line of wine
and then on your track Carlo Rossi which
dates way back
nineteen ninety-three you said the key
to set you free so give it a try but
don't mistake it for Chablis unless
you're already high and I've never heard
a rapper name check Chablis I know that
you say that you're a drinking cheap
wine at the time but that's not a cheap
wine were you paying attention to all
these different styles
what it was was uh we would drink wine
Carlos Rossi Ryan that's a white wine
wine and Chablis was like the war bland
wine the Rhine was more sweeter so
that's what we would drink and it'll get
as Moto stood we drink more but they
should leave like I mean you didn't
brought back [ __ ] believe you tripping
because it looked the same but it's not
trust and believe it's not big taste
difference so when we sent somebody to
the store they bring back should bleed
that's a party foul they must do 20 30
push-ups
all right well there you go you're ready
to move on e-40 yeah all right so this
is the bomb this [ __ ] hot I need some
water for that hoe so you're never met
one I've never I've never met one so
your career it's touched so many things
outside of music so I'm the bomb let's
focus on some efore tea Lucy's from your
more than 30 years in the public eye I
got you my man oh my god
you ever get Ashton Kutcher back for
that time that he framed you into
breaking into that car on Punk'd
he slick me I seen that man in moon was
how he doing I didn't get him back I
ain't got a chance but when I run into
him I will I figured something out he
got me though when I got Punk'd but you
know that was a beautiful thing
at the time to have my tongue hardwood
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] I don't know did
wisdom hot like that check out if you
can get on top of this you can get on
top of the rusty 40 find it my man whoo
man hold up i drugged hell of water and
everything punks it was a beautiful
thing
being on punk was a pleasure because cuz
I you know when you get pumped you
somebody if you could you know that at
that time that's what it was about being
punk you get it man yeah I mean happy
you know 40 got pumped out the day he
moved on up what do you remember about
playing gathering of the Juggalos that
always seems like an interesting hall
Juggalos many just come to have a great
time shout out to the Juggalos whoop
let's say I shout to tec-9 strange music
you feel me there's a beautiful thing
and I'm playing with the Juggalos is
great cuz you know they just come to
have a good time and they one big unit
they just they family you know
I mean and they do what they do one big
community they do their thing good
people I [ __ ] with the Juggalo is the
one investment you wish that you could
have made into Tupac's idea for the
gangster cafe you know yeah I know about
that those who don't know you can you
explain that concept not else was one
one thing pop was trying to do yeah hit
me he say Foley man look you might want
to get in on this I'm doing I want to do
you know how they got uh was at Planet
Hollywood right plant alley what you say
you're not I got playing ha I want to do
gangster cafe he was serious
[ __ ] - that would be a beautiful
thing man I wish he was still here sorry
Scott well I got the Medusa head or
whatever this is can I call somebody to
eat this eat before tea are so close
you're so close my man man dude I'm
Muslim
oh I'm [ __ ] up from this last night uh
I know what's this [ __ ] this man who you
sure brother come on come on
importing tag-teaming in a fan I'm a
cubed with that cats not talking it
Oh Rani ha how you doing my man what's
it on let me get you some water he goes
you need some milk or water what do you
want to do want some water give him this
whole [ __ ] right here he's gonna
need this right here got a clean needle
I can swing brother
so that's the one there you do what I
need to Instagram this [ __ ]
hold on playa hold on playa hold on PIPA
all right let's get it going hug it out
one down keep [ __ ] it up oh [ __ ] what
you for Louisiana somewhere now go ahead
and drink that jug cuz I don't know you
need that [ __ ] alright so hold on hold
on hold on keep there right there
it looked like we got one more to go
just have one more way to go this is the
last dab we call it the last dab because
it's tradition around here to put a
little extra on the last wing they're
cozy for tea it's going down it's going
down and what a ride it's been my man
little ride but I'm nothing to ride this
ride right here I'm telling you my [ __ ]
still [ __ ] up from the last the third
one to the last before we close the book
on hot ones complex con number three and
it's this you know e forty-year a guy
who's endured for more than 30 years
even as tastes and the economics of the
music industry have changed
efore t you always stay the same it's
tougher for young people these days to
get a sense a comfort and being
themselves and I'm curious what is e 4 t
the counselors best piece of advice for
how you can get longevity in the
entertainment industry rather than being
somebody who's constantly chasing the
next 15 minutes of clouds right it's
tough
the thing is you know you got to do what
works for you
and even if you did see what somebody
else is doing this when and try to put
your own twist to it at least you feel
me
drink some wine man expand your mind and
this feeling you feel when I'm told
right I hope that everyone was taking
notes and once again I want to say thank
you so much for coming out hot ones
complex con number three is in the books
let's hear it one more time for a 40
[Applause]
and one last time for yourselves thank
you very much we love y'all love y'all
thank you
hey what's going on spice Lords I know
you're wondering why is he shaking that
bottle why is he shaking that bottle
it's because I'm excited to announce
that the last dab products is available
now the last dab with chocolate pepper X
and pepper X you've seen your favorite
celebrities dabbing wings on the show
and now you can dab your wings at home
heat nice calm heat nice calm to order
who appreciates your spice Lords me